bienvenidos a elecciones 2022 un tour
por francia se programa en que
analizamos los principales temas de la
campaña electoral francesa tomamos
dirección hacia el lille
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y llegamos a salir la capital de la
región de los saltos de francia en el
norte del país y estamos aquí para
hablar de educación porque esta región
es una de las que tiene una de las tasas
más altas de abandono escolar de todo el
país
cuando vemos que hay jóvenes que no
tienen un computador en casa para hacer
sus tareas o una compañía bien todos los
profesores eso no es normal es de las 22
esto el ambiente que tenemos en las
clases me da mucha confianza porque
hablamos no se escucha todo eso
a
[Música]
y para mí la prioridad es permitir a la
juventud ser considerada como un valor
de la comunidad
libertad igualdad fraternidad el lema de
francia está inscrito las escuelas
públicas sin embargo este país es
criticado por su escasa movilidad social
y muchos culpan de ello al sistema de
educación
[Música]
en francia a la escuela es obligatorio
entre los 3 y los 16 años
muchas escuelas son públicas laicas y
gratuitas pero las familias son libres
de escoger una escuela particular si así
lo desean
y
desde los 3 a los 5 años los niños van a
la escuela maternal o preescolar
aquí
luego vienen 5 años de escuela primaria
para dar paso posteriormente
[Música]
a la escuela secundaria entre los 11 y
18 años conformada por el colegio y el
liceo
todos los estudios llevan a un examen el
bachillerato
los estudiantes pueden elegir una de
tres especialidades literatura estudios
económicos y sociales o ciencias y
matemáticas
la educación es el mayor gasto del
presupuesto estatal francés
56,5 billones de euros es la partida
para 2022
17 millones más que en 2021
pero los profesores franceses están
entre los peor pagados de europa el
comienzo de su carrera pueden llegar a
ganar al menos 7% menos que el promedio
en los países de la ocde
[Música]
según el informe internacional sobre
educación pisa la escuela francesa
prepara muy buenos alumnos pero sigue
siendo una de las más desiguales del
mundo
según un informe del ministerio de
educación el número de niños con
dificultades lectoras es mayor en el
norte de francia le preguntamos a los
ingleses si la educación para ellos debe
ser un tema esencial en la campaña
electoral
para mí es importante porque la
educación forma parte de mi trabajo
desde el confinamiento me doy cuenta de
que hay cosas que mejorar y podemos
hacerlo verdaderamente los políticos
debieran ocuparse de este tema e
invertir dinero en el todo
[Música]
durante el confinamiento vimos como los
barrios populares tuvieron dificultades
para mantener la educación y dar acceso
a todos sobre todo cuando vemos que hay
jóvenes que no tienen un computador en
casa para hacer sus tareas
o un acompañamiento de sus profesores
eso no es normal en 2022
[Música]
durante los debates hablan poco de la
educación se centran más en otras áreas
puede entenderlo pero pienso que la
educación debe ser importante
sobre todo cuando vemos el estado actual
de la educación creo que hay que cambiar
eso
[Música]
las diferencias sociales juegan un papel
importante de la deserción escolar
cedric ley les delegado regional de la
fed a través de esta organización los
jóvenes universitarios orientan en su
recorrido escolar de manera voluntaria a
los estudiantes de los barrios precarios
[Música]
cedric leclerc cuáles son las
principales dificultades que usted
encuentra al trabajar en educación para
hacer las principales dificultades
para nosotros en la fe son educativas
como permitimos que cada niño tenga una
educación que aspire a una profesión que
eligió y no impuesta
para nosotros esta es una desigualdad
extremadamente importante
y esto sabiendo que dependiendo de la
comunidad no todos tienen las mismas
posibilidades de éxito
en la fed
trabajamos mucho el vínculo entre la
universidad y la comunidad no para
y nos damos cuenta de que muchos jóvenes
de los barrios precarios no tienen
acceso a la educación superior y no
tienen una orientación elegida sino
impuesta por el sistema de educación
la implicación de los padres tampoco
permite a los jóvenes y más allá
y además un problema en torno al barrio
hay una censura que se hace a nivel
cultural les preguntan por qué vas a
estudiar un lugar así son muchas cosas
que hace que el norte de francia sea una
de las regiones con la tasa de abandono
más grande del país
es sobre todo un problema histórico
la industria llegó masivamente y con
ello la inmigración
ahora las industrias han sido cerradas
la minería de la cuenca minera pero
también la industria en nube
dunkerque y bueno
la gente que vino lo hizo por un trabajo
pero esas fuentes laborales se
terminaron en los años 70 y hasta los 90
todas las familias que llegaron se
quedaron sin respuestas
el gran problema aquí ahora es la nueva
generación
lo prometo
como les permitimos proyectarse a pesar
de todas las dificultades encontradas
el poste magnético
usted ha promovido varias iniciativas
dan resultados
nosotros militamos por el derecho a la
tutoría la tutoría es algo que parece
simple y es bastante complejo de
implementar de todos modos
un alumno universitario voluntario en la
fef
acompaña a un joven de un barrio
prioritario durante dos horas a la
semana
es una relación bilateral regular
de dos horas a la semana
que debe extenderse durante un periodo
suficientemente largo de seis meses y
que debe ser voluntaria
y la particularidad de este
acompañamiento es que se realiza en el
hogar de la familia
por lo tanto en estrecha relación con
los padres
los padres son integrados realmente a la
escolarización de su hijo
el intercambio que va a ver eso
hoy en la región de los altos de francia
tenemos mil 400 parejas de tutor alumno
es decir 1400 aprendices y 1.400
estudiantes tutores todos
cuáles deben ser según usted las
prioridades del próximo gobierno a nivel
de educación
para mí la prioridad es permitir a la
juventud ser considerada como un valor
de la comunidad
como el centro está en cómo la
escuchamos cómo hacemos proyectos juntos
jets de sol
como dicen hoy tenemos el control del
proyecto ciudadano que debemos hacer
yo
pero otro tema es el vínculo con la
comunidad
explicaba antes que no se tienen las
mismas posibilidades
si se vive en determinados barrios
precarios que cuando se vive en el
centro de la ciudad
no se tienen las mismas posibilidades de
éxito la pregunta es cómo creamos en
algún momento como puentes puertas de
enlace entre universidades y comunidad
muchas gracias el inglés por conceder
esta entrevista 34
sí
[Música]
la escuela también tiene un rol que
jugar a la hora de luchar por la
igualdad de oportunidades en las afueras
del hilo la directora del liceo
profesional está tendiendo puentes a
través del servicio cívico para que sus
alumnos también puedan soñar con un
futuro mejor el reportaje de karina ya
busca
a las nueve de la mañana cuando las
clases comienzan para la mayoría de los
estudiantes
hola liliana soy 'fan' sólo quería
decirte que ya es hora de levantarse
tenemos una clase las diez y media de la
mañana al proyecto en parís nos vemos
probado en gassiot estaba a cargo de una
clase aparte pero algunos de ellos
llevan dos años sin estudiar tienen que
retomar los de buenos hábitos están en
redes sociales hasta las cinco de la
mañana y la idea es animarlos a que se
levanten y vean la utilidad de venir al
alcohol
acá no hay más de dos estudiantes para
que el día tres de ellos vinieron a
trabajar en las emociones
puedes ir a la fiesta el sábado por la
noche tus papás van conmigo
bueno en serio tiene que avergonzarme
problemas de comportamiento situaciones
familiares muy difíciles esos
estudiantes de 17 años dejaron los
estudios sin haber culminado la
secundaria u obtenido un título
profesional
el instituto no es para mí no logró
encajar pero aquí está bien encajo es
sagrada
el instituto me disgusta por los
profesores el ambiente todos los otros
acá no hay calificaciones ni boletines
de notas sino talleres y tareas que
realizar
y en el programa figura la organización
de un viaje a parís para 56 personas con
discapacidades habrá desplazamientos de
personas discapacitadas
el objetivo dirigirlos
esto el ambiente que tenemos en las
clases me da mucha confianza porque
hablamos se escuchan todo es un software
el programa lanzado en el regreso a
clases de septiembre es una novedad en
francia
la idea era volver a poner al estudiante
en el centro del proyecto es decir
asegurarnos de que contrariamente a lo
que suele ocurrir que es como meter a
los alumnos en el sistema acá estamos
cambiando el sistema y asegurándonos de
que es el alumno el que está realmente
en el centro y construir todo teniendo
en cuenta sus necesidades reales
los estudiantes también deben realizar
un servicio cívico en alternancia
dos veces por semana
alicia ayuda a los jugadores del club de
rugby en silla de ruedas del libro
lo hace vivió recibe 580 euros al mes
una ayuda y quizás de una manera de
encontrar su camino
[Música]
y hasta aquí este capítulo de elecciones
2022 un tour por francia tenemos que
separarnos de nuestro querido auto
tomamos dirección hacia el aeropuerto
próxima parada el cariño francés gracias
por su preferencia
[Aplausos]